There's quite a lot of you to come and here
about make.
So, it's going to be one‑on‑one talk,
quite basic, I'm going go through the steps
of building up a decent make file, if you
already know make, and you're an expert, I
apologize, please do go next door.
I'm Rob Ashton, if you tried following me
on Twitter from the page on site it's not
spelled like that, I'm not him, don't send
abuse to him on Twitter, he'll be very confused,
send it to me here, these are things I don't
like, quite a lot of things, quite a lot of
things, these are things do like, needles
to say I don't like very much.
Some context, I work in a team of predominantly
airline developers, beard wearing E Mac users,
a lot of C, a lot of bash and a lot of make,
our C and airline are Polished diamonds and
wrapped up in duck take and that's bash and
make, because of this it made sense to use
make for our JavaScript, it may not make sense
for you.
I'm not Evanial rising, yet I kind of am though
I haven't seen a nice tidy grump file.
I found this picture on a make web site, I
quite like it.
Apparently it's afully Gnu, however you say
it, looks like it was drawn by a three‑year‑old,
drawn by a thirty‑year‑old, make, as old
as the hills, it solved all the problems and
solved all the problems in weird wacky ways
which makes it super fun, I always have established
that if you're using cowboys language like
JavaScript, and it is, and mind as well use
cowboy tuning around it.
Try to keep professional‑‑ like grump
or gulp, and arrange everything in a tiny
nice streams, it's all very fun, but it's
not as fun as wading through obscure symbols
and traversing where to‑‑ I really enjoy
this find it entertaining, so yes, that's
why make, I'm going to jump right into what
make is, and do some demos because it's more
E.
siting.
And more importantly, what make is not, so
over here if this directory, I've got some
stuff, I haven't got any cool music, to play.
You hum or whatever, do a dance.
Use your imagination now.
I have a recursor file to make something in
it.
I just want to demonstrate that make is not
procedural.
So, here I have a variable and signs whatever
the value of 2 is, like another variable and
assign it to where there's all there $3 is,
3 is equal to hello world, down here in the
all target, make that bigger, you can all
see it.
That look good in the back ?
yeah, yeah, we're good, okay, cool.
I'm going to echo out, do whatever is in the
value of 3.
And if I run this.
So, over here we get hello world printed out
which is quite interesting if you read that
top down, all these variables are lacy, value
of a point of actual use them, it's called
variable expansion, these are recuresively,
actually, I got that wrong, these are meant
to be‑‑ O Oop, whatever.
Forget everything I just said.
I, if I go into supervise over here, you also
have these ones, semi colon in there instead,
these are actually evaluated at the point
of time, which means in my all over here if
I echo out the value of one p ...
t Ooops, I should not have worked,‑‑
that should not have worked, I did everything
wrong.
I'm doomed to fail already.
Ooops, meant to do that, quite, so, any way,
because of the semicolon, because of this
channel over here, these are values of execution,
value of one over here is nothing, this is
kind of important, make is all about expanding
expressions, whether those expressions are
simple variable assignment, function calls
to get list of crap, not really important.
What we have a very non‑procedural language,
recursive variables are lacy, simple expanded
variables are not (Laze city) so whatever,
I'm going to use recursive variables everywhere
in these demos what is the structure of a
make file, what does it look like? Well, it's
separated out into these things called targets,
prerecs, and recipes, I try ouse the terminology
on the side I call it a big pile of make and
get on with life.
That's not to everyone's taste.
I have a very simple set up in a directory,
very simple copy.
Okay, we have a make file and we have an in
directory, in our in directory we have a file
called Pinki file, rainbow dash is not best
pony if you don't know this, you do now.
It's a truism.
‑‑ we have a make file, right.
I'm going to copy and paste from down here
rather than try to write things, I think I'm
in demo fail mood today this is preparation,
it is, right, so what I'm going to do over
here, I'm going to define a target, it's a
directory called out, we have Pinkie text,
and it has independency on Pinki.text.
And also dependency on out, which is nice,
copy and paste.
The press pee is found underneath this.
So here I have in Pinkie text and out Pinkie
text.
And here we have a target called out, which
is directory, and we simply say, please make
the directory called out.
Over here we're just echoing Dev null‑‑
if I run this, so I go to simple copy and
say, hey, please make that, you'll see here
it copied over my Pinkie and rain by, if I
run it again, it doesn't anything at all.
Make is quite clever when you have targets
and dependents set up, it looks at files and
times stamps and only dose things when something
is different than expected.
If I go to Pinkie text and say Pinkie pie
is the best pony it will only copy Pinkie.text.
If you set up a decent dependency graph, it
will be clever about what it runs and doesn't
run.
This is the best thing about make.
I believe that was the only point I wanted
to make here, really, we can go copying of
Gumpf.
We have a target,list of prerequisites and
they execute from right to left.
Got that, of course we did, excellent.
What we learned here are targets that are
actual physical outputs on the disk, prerequisites
can be files or other targets you're executing
and recipes are scripts that execute to make
the targets appear from the dependencies.
Nothing too exciting.
Of course, that make file was awfully crap,
I can't sit there and write a make file for
every single file for my input and out put
directories because this would take me all
day, so we have patterns, rules.
Let's do a demo of that.
So, let's go to my patent directory.
So, here I have the exact same make fail,
I just made before.
That's wrong keyboard short cut, I'm normally
a Linux usually, I just closed it instead
of VM, I'm going to present that happened.
I don't know my keyboard short cuts on Mac
OS, I'm afraid, I make mistakes all the time.
Okay, Kayry on.
So here we have really crap make file because
we're copying files independently all the
time, we can use pattern rules do this, actually
if we have a, if we call a target where it's
any pattern matching out/something.text.
Then, actually, dependency will be in something.text,and,
down here, we can actually take the value,
which we've got from above, which will be‑‑
is it a ...
it's an angle wrack et, of course it is the
incantations are important.
I want a copy from here, wrong keyboard short
cut again and I'm getting confused on Mac
OS that the control key is in the wrong place,
it always gets me.
So, isn't that exciting, with can say, this
is a magic automatic variable given to us
by make that says whatever the target is,
please put it in dollar open angle bracket
and the other one dollar at whatever our first
prerequisite was.
We still have up here all out slash Pinkie
and rainbow text and they will part earn match
on the target over here and they'll both work
so if I go and run that, I say, make, that
actually works and expands to Pinkie and rainbow
and works like it did before.
Which is super awesome and nice, we saw here
something really nice, which is we have pattern
rules where we have substitutions with that
lovely percent symbol, automatic variables
are exposed to recipes from the targets and
prewe can we sits we have a magic list of
incantations that will get things out of the
list.
You start memorizing the incantations, I've
forgotten them because I'm on stage and panicking.
There are dozens of them, it makes it clear
to read, when cru near a can have fee shop
and peek looking over your shoulder they think
you're dead clever.
Make has a Maureen Bunyan of of built in functions.
The thing with make file, I don't really like
is that over here I'm having to do out/pin
I can and out slash rainbow as my actual targets,
well, that's kind of crap because I don't
want to write out all of my targets manually
in my make file, it's rubbish, I can call
functions instead.
I'm going to do that over here, inputs, I
can generate a list of inputs over here, and
say, actually if I call this function wild
card and match on anything in the in directory,
asterisk, and‑‑ please put it in a variable
called inputs thank you very much.
Well, that's not very useful, because, of
course, I want to replace out/Pinkie and out/rainbow
over here, so I can call more‑‑ I can
call more function on my inputs.
6 Ooops, and Ooops again.
There we go.
And I Kayk say, actually can you do a pattern
substitute on in/whatever and replace that
whatever without/whatever on all the inputs.
And now I have a list of out puts.
I can actually print out this list, going
to hide this entire line now, so, of I say,
I'm going to echo out my output.
And for good measure, inputs as well.
Of that's no good.
Of did I mention I don't know my keyboard
short cuts on Mac OS, I'm hitting all the
wrong keys, so if I run this make file, you'll
see over here my output list contain out/rainbow
of and out/Pinkie, and the include list‑‑
I've general herb rated a list of file and
replaced the expressions with something else.
My inputs and out puts.
I can feed these outputs into my of target
over here as a dependency.
And that will mash past this out/and I'll
execute this against everything, these inputs
over here aren't actually used but to build
out puts collections, another exam you might
chose to did that, so I'm going to echo to
Den null, I don't like to print out, so I
run this now, actually executed, so I copy
over my Pinkie to my output directory, because
if I cat out/Pinkie, and cat out/rainbow we
see that Pinki pie still best pony and dash
is not best pony.
We can generate list of inputs using wild
cards and we can generate a list of outputs
by pat ton producing on that list, that is
cool when combine that with pat enrules, you
go and scan your fold erstructure, which is
known for the structure for all the files
you were to input into various command line
tools and generate the outputs you want out
of that and generate big part targets out
of that and run all your code and hopefully
you end up with come peopling an application
which is super cool this is why Pinkie pie
is best pony because she plays all the instruments.
I'm going to build something that's roughly
equatable to a real world example.
It's not going to be a real world example
because I adopt want to play with barrels
of fire and MPM and reactor fire that I would
use in a java application, I'm going to go
incompared my vanilla, that this is not how
I do things in the real world too much.
I didn't want to start throwing in all sorts
of crazy concepts.
Over here I have a similar widgets directory,
in my simple widgets directory, never mind‑‑
I have a widgets folder in that widgets folder
we have three wig its, once one's called Celestia,
Pink Ie, and rainbow, each have a style sheet,
have an index file, and they have some images
too, so pictures of Celest aye as a child
and groan up.
I don't want to know what they're composed
of, but I have a convention in any project
that all widgets have some kind of index enindustry
point and some kind of style sheet, and I
want to copy all that across so this index
file will actually work, I'm referencing budgets.CSS
and J S, and they magically appear over here,
in here in the real world I would use browser
five, this is a nice simple example.
I have two outputs here at least, and wig
its.CSS and I have widgets in these folders,
and copy them as welt.
Real project you might want to put them in
image map, we're not going to do that today.
Thankfully I have it all down here before,
copy and paste everything again.
Absolutely wonderful.
The first thing I always do when making a
mu make file is figure out my nut output files
and work my way up.
It's clear I have two outputs over here.
And these outputs are going to have to be‑‑
they're completely wrong, got the wrong file
open.
There we go.
Of wow.
Okay, good.
So hereby I want to make a widget.JS and clearly
I'm going to need some JavaScript files and
I'm going to need some CS file to point over
there.
So how am I going to get those, let's go to
the top of the file over hering let's go and
get some expansions.
So ...
if I have some coffee files in each wig it,
over here, I'm going to wild card against
one it/against whatever the wig it is and
anything that's coffee in the directory, and
generate a list of output files from that,
placing all the coffee with J Ses, obviously
as you do, going do the same with stylus files,
I want to take take all the stylus files,/whatever,/whatever
file, success files are going to look like
that, the file replaced by CSS, make sense
so far? Of course it does, nothing complicated
here at all.
I hope not any way.
So, cool, I'm going to if he cuss on CSS and
such for now, what I need to do is I need
to somehow convert all my JavaScript files‑‑
my coffee files to JavaScript files before
calf Nateing them.
To do that we need to compile them.
That's the coffee script Compiler, if I gather
up all of my .
If I gather up all of my coffee files over
here as dependencies, one it/whatever coffee,
and we have widget/whatever JS, coffee script
Compiler against the target I want generated.
Which will work perfectly fine.
It's quite clear that if I want to generate
a pile of one it of CSS, I can do the same
thing.
Take the files, general ate some outputs.
If I want to execute these rules I'm going
to have to say, well, actually let's make
two place holder rules over here, we have
style and we have coffee.
The style and coffee by the way go intinesically
hand in hand, if you haven't got coffee, you
haven't got style.
Out put CSS files goes to/site‑‑ success
and output files‑‑ nothing over there.
Of soft here if I call coffee, it's going
to match against this rule for every single
JS file and look at the coffee spiel, look
at coffee script against any file that hasn't
been change in the recent times, which is
nice.
So, if I go over here, and I want to generate
my code, I can say over here, well, if I want
to do the code, I want to execute the coffee
script Compiler, and I want to make the wig
it.
JS file, so over here offul I'm confusing
myself, I hope you're following.
We take all the J S output files and we cut
them all together in really horrible way,
so I hope semi colon in the file, there will
be semi colon, because we're using coffee
script, if there wasn't semi colons then this
wouldn't work.
Friends don't let friends use semi colons.
I'm going to make a clean directory over here
because it's polite.
It's good to be polite.
Let's love the images for now though.
Cool.
I'm going to save say my all depends on my
code and my style.
I'm going to echo this down to receive/Nul.
Cool, so what we've (Dev/Null‑‑ we generated
targets for them which are JavaScript and
another target a JavaScript target file and
we have a nice pipeline of individual files
to individual files to one big file.
Which is super cool.
And because I don't trust my copy and paste,
I'm going to copy and paste all this over
here.
Let's pretend I live code all of this.
So, I'm going to copy all of my CSS across
into one file, my JavaScript file, I run this.
Over here.
And we see here, around my JavaScript Compiler,
I did everything like that, run, fine, fine,
if I run page again, nothing at all, nothing
needs to be done, because nothing's changed,
which is super cool, I'ming going to make
clean.
One of the great things about make, once you
have all the targets set up and doing things
on a file by file basis, this is important,
it's very easy to parallelize, using make/J
parallelizes all of that and super quick,
you get this for free if you build a sensible
composed make file comprised of lots of small
targets and small files that's granular you
can get a fast build process out of the grate
by parallelizing it for free.
The site made, there's my Http servers if
I go to Safari or Chrome.
Pinkie Pie and Celestia.
These are my wig it, they you click on them
and they do things.
It's cool.
Okay, cool.
Of so, we'll see here that we is av a wig
it CSS and image directory of everything copied
across, I have a make file‑‑ in a nice
granular way, now the thing is, this is kind
of cool, you have a make file which opens
and compos very well, place holder files,
time stamps and we have automatic parallelism,
clearly if you're on windows it doesn't works,
but I don't really care about that.
This make file is not perfect, obviousfully
a real world, it's probably browserfy against
JavaScript files, we probably reexecute make
on a per one it basis you can do more explicit
pattern matching Andrea have a widgets folder
that we pattern match on the module folder
that's I do at my workplace, I load modules
contain all the JavaScript, all of the CSS,
all images, pattern match against a module
derricktory, we can build image maps out put
CSS and paralyze and it's super fast only
things that change get copies across, which
is awesome.
Quite a lot of stream based pipelines forego
that, and put them through a stream and complicated
and hard to understand, come collated but
also incredibly simple.
Reuse, I've spent all this time making an
amazing make file, it this case it wasn't
amazing, it was simple, but my work one is
probably 500 lines of make, I want to reuse
across all my lines of projects, they have
a similar structure all of my projects, how
do I do that .
let's look at that.
Shall we.
What I've done is on to GitHub I've pushed
this reproand there's an assets folder over
here where I have common.Merk, nothing's changed,
except for over here we have a conditional
assignment of widget to widgets, so widget
had been specified by the caller of this make
file, we'll actually not sign this variable,
so in my current project I want to call widgets
gadgets or baubles or something, I don't know.
And the thing over here, I have the default
goals, I will always call goal unless I specify
a goal myself.
What I can then do is inside my‑‑ inside
a make file on an actual project, that's empty
because I he want it to be empty, of course
we go, clef er.
Of we can export some configuration for that,
you can say export widget port equals baubles,
the make files to that we invoked at this
point, set a target at common.America, if
we haven't got a common.Mk, go and get it‑‑
comment.mk, this is what our make files look
at work, which downloads a latest version
of our make and goes and gets it, are if I
run this right now, hopefully on the WiFi,
it sound loaded the make file into common.Mk,and
executed against bauble directory and gave
me a site, so, there we go, baubles, CSS,
and Html, it's exactly the same as before,
just ponies.
I say just ponies, I'm very fond of ponies,
no such thing as ponies, they're awesome.
Boot strapping our make files, we can export
variables which is super cool, you can set
default goals, which is useful.
And, if you have a set of conventions across
your projects you can use your make files
across all things and get much joy and happiness
from your life.
Especially as your make files look very pretty.
Here's a friendly warning of something not
to do.
This is what I see quite a lot with Mk files,
I see this a lot GitHub‑‑ we have targets
call build JS and they invoke some command
line against an entire directory of JavaScript,
and then we have pony directives down there,
these are not real output these execute these
every single time and make is being used as
a task runner, I see this a lot not in node
projects but this airline projects as well,
but the common‑‑ airline is a glorified
bash script made in make, it's really slow,
it's not doing any additional compilation,
it's just compiling every single bean file
inset of asking if it's out of date.
Build systems are not task runners, and vice
versa, not true, one of the mistakes I see,
one of the problems I see all the time that
grunt and GitHub being used as a combination
of these things that's why t's confusing,
if you just want a task runner, that's what
NPM scripts are for‑‑ in my workplace
it's a bash scripts calling a bunch of bash
scripts we're a bunch of coy boys that's what
we like do‑‑ cowboys‑‑ these two
things go together very well, close tools
wisely, that's it and I am running out of
time, I was right about having to rush myself
a little bit.
If you want to come and tell me how awful
it was, do so outside over coffee or breed
do not to the wrong Robb Ashton‑‑ thank
you very much, that was make (Applause)